Tương dấu anh đầu tiên đến thế tự trụ của công nghệ việt.
Tương anh đầu đặt chất đến NWC, Bắc Sê Lona,
Măng thiếu những thích bị việc thông đầu tiên sau Việt Nam tự nhiên kinh và sát sốt,
sau khi một thập kịt đồng hành.
Vì theo, tại dự duy nhất của Việt Nam không chỉ dự kỳ công nghệ,
mắc con chơi thấy tính thành giận sản cảnh trang,
kết nối sau hành trẻ sân trời gút để.
Năm ai ngàn không trăm hai lắm,
với thông nghiệp sản tạo công nghệ bị giữ và triệu bị bước,
vì theo với ra hạn có dự tích và trường mới vùng,
với tổng cộng thành hai sản khẩm tự hạn tất hạn mời nắm cơ hiện đại.
Nếu tàn số một chắc vẫn chăm mấy khi mệt năm,
tới những giải phát, ứng dụng ai ai thông mình.
Các sản tập được lựa chọn dựa chết đều chi,
mới, đồ phát, có ra chị thực hiện,
không chỉ buộc tị trường trong lớp,
mắc con phát triệu ở mười tị trường nước ngoài,
cũng như dụng khẩu bị các buông ra như ở nộ,
Philipease, uả em.
Bình kệ đó, mấy hát như bại tháng tựa trường tác,
với các công ty công nghệ hàng đầu đã được ký gái,
tự nâng đau góc mặt,
về theo không chỉ thật định bị tế phức trử của công nghệ để năng,
mắc con chất thấy năng lựa phát triệu và hội nhập.
Tế hiện năng lựa của công nghệ về trình đầu trử của tế.